[Applause]
it's going on conk on ya they stuck me
in right before lunch so I gotta bring a
little bit of energy for you guys don't
be thinkin about that food alright so
what I want to teach you is how
beardbrand has built our YouTube channel
okay
a little bit about us beardbrand these
are some very handsome guys especially
the guy on the left our mission is to
foster confidence through grooming so
our goal out there is we think we can
make the world better by giving men the
tools they need to invest in themselves
when they invest in themselves they can
invest in their family and their careers
and their communities and it all starts
with the person you're looking back in
the mirror so we wrap that up with a
tagline which is keep on growing which
is trying to get our audience and our
customers to continue to invest in
themselves continue to grow and of
course like have some really cool
gnarlybeard's our YouTube channel is
more than just me it actually started
off with me and then we added these
other very very handsome guys and we
have guests collaborators and we'll talk
about that a little bit more but you'll
see on the right side is our barbershop
series and we go into a barber shop and
we'll film it it's very kind of relaxing
like ASMR does anyone know you somewhere
but anyways I kind of hated putting this
slide in here like why YouTube I feel
like I go to my fair share of
conferences and people are always
talking about like Facebook and how to
make for Facebook and a lot of the
previous talk present ators presenters
presenters were talking about how to you
know write for Facebook and then of
course like blogging and writing for
content but no one so for me it's
talking about YouTube now YouTube is an
incredible platform it's an awesome
platform in fact it is the second most
popular website it is more popular than
Facebook
it is this second most popular search so
only Google has YouTube beat and they
kind of work together anyway so between
YouTube and Google
you gotta be on there well you don't
have to be on there and you'd be on
there if you want but it is huge an
interesting stat about YouTube is there
is 1 billion hours of videos being
watched per day all right so just just
take a moment to think about that 1
billion so if if you had a billion
people that means they were on YouTube
for an hour and chances are you guys
aren't watching YouTube for an hour so
it's just the the amount of people on
YouTube is obscene Facebook has this
little bait-and-switch tactic where they
they allow your posts to show to
everyone and you're like oh man this
Facebook thing is pretty great I can
post something organically and it gets
shown to all these people and they're
like not so fast we're gonna pull that
back and now you got to start paying us
for it whereas YouTube is a platform
that's like hey you're creating content
for us sweet here's more audience for
you and not only that there's some money
we're gonna give you money so YouTube is
YouTube actually pays us to make content
so it blows my mind why people all right
and the other good thing is anyone in
here can start typing in fact some of
y'all are typing right now and you can
put that typing stuff on a blog post in
an article on a Facebook post on Twitter
that's pretty easy to do like it's a
pretty low barrier to entry to have a
blog and subsequently there's tons of
blogs probably for whatever industry
you're in you're gonna have more
competition on a blog or social media
platform then you're going to have on
YouTube it is a little bit more
challenging to create video so it is not
easy but if it's something that you
dedicate to you can build systems and
processes to make it easy and you'll
find that you're not running into as
many competitors
all right so let's get into beard R and
how did we do it we're as Adam said
we're a bootstrap company we started 30
box
we've got no loans we're debt-free no
outside money no investors anything like
that
yeah Mansa we're hustling all right
but first so the talk of this if you're
gonna tell is how we got to 50 million
views in YouTube but I do have a
confession we're only at 49 million so
the thing is we're getting 175,000 views
a day I tried to convince Sam to move
this back a week so I would officially
be at 50 million but they were not
having any of that so the beauty of
YouTube is it is like compounding
interest and like the pity hoarder is
probably going to relate they love
compound interest I love compound
interest
who doesn't love compound interest you
do the same amount of work and you get
more out of it so let's take a look at
beard brands growth over the years so in
2012 is when we started 2012 our first
video was February 8 it was a really bad
video in fact all those videos in 2012
were bad except for one we're able to
get a stunning huge growth in one year
of what just under 300 279 followers at
first year and only 40,000 or 60,000
views but you'll see we doubled the
content 2013 got a significant amount of
subscribers and that trend continues
you'll see that the the common thread of
our YouTube channel is each year we're
producing more and more content and
we're learning how to produce content so
that investment into YouTube comes back
because how the user works is on YouTube
and they'll watch a video and YouTube
does a great job of showing your other
videos to them so they'll go down this
rabbit hole of watch
two or three or five or six of your
videos all in one sitting
whereas in facebook it's about how the
user Scrolls through their feed and
you're lucky to get one in there or a
couple in there but there's no
opportunity to really like maximize and
build that that audience and that that
content you're producing so let's dive
deeper into our growth like I like being
an open book showing you how it is I
don't think a lot of people out there
will will show you their dashboards this
is our lifetime views for our channel
and I've got certain blue marks
highlighted here and you'll see there's
like little bumps so the little bump
little bump little bump and this is over
about what six years those little bumps
are going to be the seasonality of our
channel so we're in one right now we
call a growing season where all the
dudes seem to grow their beards out in
November I love growing season it is my
favorite season of the year if you guys
aren't growing a beard out right now I
highly recommend it it's great so
YouTube is going to have like a natural
kind of cadence and I guess abdun flows
you know the summer is actually pretty
pretty slow a lot of the college kids
will head home and apparently when
they're in school all they do is watch
YouTube and when they leave school they
don't do anything else but I want to
point out a couple other impressive
marks so going back to my previous slide
where we talked about how we were
creating more content on a yearly basis
these red marks indicate when we shifted
from so like the first red mark we're
doing very sporadically like one a month
one every two month and then we finally
got up to one video a month
and we did that for about a year and
then you'll see a little bit of boost in
that and then we moved up to to a
two-week excuse me somewhere in between
the first and the second post and then
at the
the middle red one it's one that was
when we moved up to four post a week and
then this one right here before the huge
spike we've gone up to daily content so
every single day there's going to be a
new video on our beardbrand channel so
how did we do that it's easy to say just
create a video every single day but how
many videos do you think you can make
talking about growing a beard oh we have
over 500 videos and to answer your
question to grow a beard out you just
wait it's been a little bit of a
challenge so our strategy is a lot of
pretty good videos over less really good
videos and there's no right or wrong
strategy with anything so like our
blueprint works for us it works for our
preferences and techniques and our
workflows but for some people they may
prefer you know really investing a lot
of time and energy I know some YouTube
channels that have just absolutely blown
up and grown to millions of subscribers
and viewers and views almost overnight
just posting one video a month primitive
technology how many of you guys watch
primitive technology okay
you all should put a note because that's
like my favorite channel it's just some
dude in the woods and he's like
hammering around in bare feet I don't
get it but it's like it's very relaxing
and it's he has this like little stories
talent so so there is opportunity to
create content in consistently I would
say and still see success but the thing
with that guy from primitive technology
is he's like literally living in the
woods a month of the time and I think it
takes him probably like months to find
an outlet to charge up his camera
so our strategy is like I we don't
really have that good of ideas to be
able to create like these really
incredible stories or videos so what
we're going to do is figure out how can
we create a lot of content and the way
that we've done that is multiple hosts
so you'll see you saw earlier we had
three guests that are pretty much
regulars we're trying to get that up to
seven regulars and then that way we'll
have like seven different people's take
on how to grow a beard and you know some
guys have curlier beard some guys have
gray beard some guys have long beard
short beards just give that diversity of
information but it also goes like your
hairstyle your grooming so we've
branched out beyond the beard it's more
than just the beard it's the hair it's
grooming and it's also self-improvement
going back to the keep on growing all
right collaborations with other creators
are a big opportunity I think as
marketers we kind of get into this this
trap of just wanting to push our product
and just living in our own little bubble
and just thinking of ourselves and and
also seeing like competitors as like a
fixed pie mentality right so if someone
gets a view on their channel that was
one less view that I could have gotten
on our channel now maybe it's like
slightly true for some instances like we
have this one youtuber who we will not
name who has like copied a lot of our
content and come up with a competing
company we're like I got really really
frustrated with that I guess for lack of
better words but there are other guys
out there who also talk about beards but
but beards aren't their thing right
they're not selling the same similar
products that we're selling we sell
men's grooming products so being able to
have them come onto our channels is one
way to do a collaboration going on to
the other channel is also so what I'll
do is like a beard growing tutorial and
I'll give that content
- let's say another big channel out
there is called alpha M and he does like
lifestyle stuff and style stuff so I'll
do a collaboration with him he'll post
it on our channel or his channel and
then we'll get a lot of new subscribers
who come over from there and not only
that like the reality is the people on
YouTube it is a community there are the
comments out there and these viewers are
watching multiple channels and what
happens is when you do a collaboration
they become like all part of the
community so it's like all this like
special Club they're like oh no my
favorite beard guy just got with my
favorite star guy oh snap
that is literally what they're doing on
their computer when they watch our
videos or at least that's how I imagine
it an interesting take though is don't
let like your similar channels be your
only opportunity for collaborations like
think about opportunities beyond that
for instance we did a collaboration with
a youtuber who has a DIY channel like
they're making he makes like concrete
tables and benches and stuff and that
has like nothing to do with our channel
and really like his audience has nothing
to do with our channel but what he did
is he drove into Austin and we made a
bench for our beardbrand office so it
was good content for him and then I got
to make a little guest appearance on his
channel and get a little bit exposure
there so just kind of spread your
tentacles creatively as you can so we've
done them with like comedians we've done
them with like I said the DI wires and
I'm actually working on one now with a
car channel and a guy who like fixes up
cars and and of course like you've got
to like use your creativity to find new
opportunities to build those
collaborations
okay there was a third one which is
watch time now watch time is a big thing
for YouTube watch time is really the
metric that they're hammering home on
and and it's really like how they're
beating Facebook right cuz because
Google and Facebook they're not the best
of friends are competing Facebook
stabbing they now get more views on
videos and then Google is like hey yeah
but of you is like three seconds of
someone scrolling by it that's like no
one's not really watching that so Google
has made this strategic decision
probably about two years ago to get
people to spend more time on YouTube and
really focus on watch time now watch
time is a kind of vague metric at
YouTube and what it is it's not simply
the amount of views you have divided by
how long you watch a video it takes into
consideration when the person comes to
YouTube what video brought them to
YouTube what they did while on YouTube
and then what video did they last watch
before they left so what you want to do
is encourage people to get onto YouTube
watch a whole bunch of videos spend more
than an hour right and then leave when
they watch someone else's videos not
your video so you don't want to be
having in all your videos content that's
driving people back to your website if
at the end of it you're like hey go to
my website buy this buy this buy this
then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna hammer your watch time and by
hammering your watch time Google is
going to be like yeah I don't want to
throw any bones this way because he's
kicking everyone off YouTube so you want
to be able to think about building that
community on YouTube understanding that
it's okay for them to get connected on
YouTube and